We looked around and we noticed that almost everyone around us had phones...
...and everyone was complaining about their phones.
And we thought, "Could we build something better?"
You know, it's a roller coaster ride.
And if it ain't scary, it ain't fun.
Steve came to one of our design meetings and he said, "This isn't good enough."
Like, "This is it."
"You have to come up with something so much better."
"This is not good enough."
Everyone got up and started demoing the keyboards they've created.
And some of these were just crazy.
I mean, you do these gestures,...
...these super complex gestures that were really hard to learn.
Was multi-touch touch screen actually going to deliver a "good enough?"
And how good is "good enough" compared to this keyboard, this Crackberry keyboard?